e
[Music]
good morning everybody uh trying to get
all our education committee members in
here hurting cat Bo yeah HT hurting cats
okay I'd like to welcome all the uh
folks from the public and those from the
LBA here today to present this report uh
we have about an hour an hour and a half
here you know we we have enough time I
think to at least become more informed
on it everybody here on the committee
should have a copy of the the report
with you this this blue copy right
here mine has a lot of yellow
highlighted areas within throughout
uh so what I'd like to do is I'd like to
have Jay Henry come forward here and
maybe Jay you could introduce your staff
LBA you have Christine Young and Paige
Loren uh so I don't know Paige
Christine
okay good morning Mr chairman and U
members of the committee for the record
I'm Christine Young the director of
audits for the
LBA we are here to present the
performance audit report for the
Department of Education special
education dispute resolution processes
Paige Loren an audit manager with our
office was the InCharge manager on this
audit and she'll present the
report and also joining Us in the back
um from the Department of Education is
Christine Brennan the Deputy
Commissioner uh also Diana Fenton the
chief of the governance unit and um
Becky fet the director of the Bureau of
special education support uh this audit
topic was recommended in Senator
Reagan's 2021 final report of the
committee to study special education
dispute resolution options and uh before
I turn it over to paig for the
presentation I'll note that this audit
was presented to the fiscal committee on
March 15 and it was approved for
release the purpose of the audit was to
assess the question how effectively did
the Department of Education manage
special education dispute resolution
processes during State fiscal years 2020
through
2022 we reviewed over 16 00 regulatory
requirements and corresponding internal
controls for six processes available
through the department to help parents
and schools resolve special education
disputes these were primarily issues
related to students with an
IEP the report includes a background
section and three chapters we will pause
after presenting each section to provide
an opportunity for questions or comments
and with that I will turn it over to
Paige for the presentation of the
report thank you
Christine good morning has Christine
introduced me and my name is Paige
Lauren getting right into the executive
summary in page one we found the
department lacked adequate controls and
did not effectively manage dispute
resolution
processes existing controls were not
were limited informal inconsistently
implemented and not clearly documented
or communicated dispute resolution
requirements were unnecessarily complex
an issue we first reported on in
1991 many Department requirements were
established through ad hoc rules which
could not be enforced we also found
Department practices were not always
consistent with laws and rules
ineffective internal controls and the
resulting issues we identified
compromise compliance and transparency
and potentially compromise State
eligibility for federal ass assistance
ineffectiveness also added unnecessary
costs and St and barriers for parents
and other stakeholders our
recommendation summary begins on page
five the department con concurred fully
or in part with all 20 of the
observations in the report five
observations may require legislative
action which I will note when it's
applicable our background chapter starts
in page
11 and summarizes the state complaint
due process complaint mediation neutral
conference thirdparty moderated
discussion and facilitated ippt meeting
dispute resolution
processes table one on page 12 provides
the regulatory structure and type of
contract for each
process State complaint due process
complaint and mediation were federally
required while neutral conference
thirdparty moderated discussion and
facilitated IEP meeting processes were
developed and made available by
Department starting on page 14 figures
included in the background chapter also
visually summarize the dispute
resolution requirements for the six
processes red text within the figure
show federal or state requirements that
were not followed in
practice starting on page
21 figures four five and six include
dark shaded boxes with white text
indicating unauthorized informal
practices which were not established in
laws or
rules
figure 7 on page 25 provides an overview
of the organizational structure of
special education dispute resolution
process responsibilities as of June 30th
2022 six full-time staff had supervisory
or direct responsibility for dispute
resolution processes during the audit
period five of six staff had additional
non-sp special education dispute
resolution responsibilities the six
staff member eventually acquired
additional unrelated responsibilities
after the audit period this concludes
the background chapter if there are any
questions at this point okay from the
committee are there any questions on
that the next section we're going to get
into is management control and I think
that's where we're going to have a lot
of questions uh are there any questions
so
far page why why don't you continue then
please our management control chapter
starts in page
27 and contains eight observations
addressing deficiency systemically
effect ing special education dispute
resolution
processes well-designed properly
implemented and monitored controls can
help efficiently and effectively achieve
objectives ensure responsibilities are
fulfilled and ensure operations remain
consistent as we discussed in
observation number one management
oversight of the existing limited
controls was ineffective and management
significantly relied on staff members
institutional knowledge to carry out
responsibilities many operational
deficiencies resulted which adversely
affected special education dispute
resolution responsibilities and known
risks were
unmitigated observation number two
starts on page
31 the observation discusses lack of
strategic strategic planning processes
or plans aligning dispute resolution
processes to Department wide mission to
achieve objectives performance and
decision-making were not supported by
quantitative assessments which
negatively impacted operations examples
observation number three starts on page
35 processes were generally managed
independent of each other without
adequate controls to ensure dispute
resolution efficiency and Effectiveness
there were no plans supporting
organizational changes or assessments of
Staff
responsibilities as a result
non-compliance occurred and
responsibilities were not always
fulfilled observation number four on
page
40 addresses stakeholder engagement and
collaboration processes which are
critical for management to understand
and set dis Ute resolution
expectations formalizing engagement and
collaboration processes could have
helped the department promote
transparency support process Improvement
and use resources
efficiently however we found stakeholder
engagement and collaboration processes
were not formalized in varied among
stakeholders this compromised
transparency and contributed to
inefficiency and
ineffectiveness starting on page
45 observation number five addresses
effective contract man management
controls we found existing controls were
minimal and unimplemented monitoring was
inadequate and management did not
formalize training requirements contract
terms were incomplete and terms included
in contracts were inconsistently
fulfilled which contributed to
non-compliance Observation number six
starts on page
50 and discusses implementing strategic
Contracting processes to ensure enough
qualified individuals are contracted for
dispute resolution
processes the management did not ensure
the department contracted with with
enough qualified individuals to fulfill
dispute resolution Regulatory and
contract requirements including for the
scheduling of
contractors additionally some
contractors did not conduct certain
processes for which they were contracted
53 observation number seven starts on
page
55 the observation addresses controls
over conflicts of interest for
Department staff
contractors and parties to dispute
resolution processes we found controls
were not comprehensive and conflicts of
interest risk were not sufficiently
mitigated impartiality and Independence
requirements for staff and contractors
were inconsistently understood
implemented and followed additionally
parents did not always know how to
report potential conflicts of interests
we identified several actual conflicts
of interest which occurred for one
dispute resolution process during the
audit period legislative action may be
required to address our recommendations
to establish comprehensive impartiality
Independence
requirements observation number eight
60 the observation addresses developing
controls to comprehensively understand
monetary and non-monetary costs
associated with administering special
education dispute resolution
processes we found Associated controls
were inadequate which resulted in waste
and increased fraud risk the department
also did not objectively evaluate cost
stakeholders incurred while using
dispute resolution processes and
identify improvements to help address
costs this concludes the first chapter
if there are any questions at this
point okay are there questions from the
committee I'd like to roll back a little
bit here okay we we're starting um on
page
two under state laws there's a source
where the responsibility comes
from and I'm concerned that where the
issue is not performed not performed not
performed is mentioned four times uh
three time two times for the state and
then uh the others one or two times the
when you're doing this are you asking
the question why are they not
performed in conjunction with state law
we do I I believe some of the areas we
found was an un awareness of the the
requirement so some staff just did not
know this was a requirement um I not
sure if this
is I believe in observation number three
we talk about delegation of authority
and it's a contributing factor that it
was established in laws and rules but it
wasn't formally delegated to staff so
several of us served with uh John Reagan
when we went through this several years
back and requested the LBA audit and I
think this is reflecting some of the
concerns page
31 under observation number two
management did not proactively evaluate
and address issues or provide adequate
oversight of
controls consequently dispute resolution
processes were ineffectively managed
with negatively impacted nhed New
Hampshire education
stakeholders um that's exactly what we
were hearing when we went with the the
uh Advocate the special education
Advocate um and I'd like to know perhaps
a little later from the Department where
are we on trying to ensure that this is
occurring properly and then I'm just
going through some of the areas that I
have so maybe I can wake up some of the
36 uh underneath inadequate controls
over organizational
structure organiz organizational charts
incompletely reflected the
reorganization New Hampshire e education
rules guides and manuals contain 90
outdated and dis discrepant discrepant
organizational references information on
how the public could contact staff about
special education dispute resolution
processes was inconsistent unclear or
outdated again that reflects back to why
John
pushed for the
audit and then going on to page um 18
under table
four uh New Hampshire shall evaluate the
effectiveness of alternate dispute
resolution annually annually no one
responsible for it in table
four
um going on to page
45 under observation five where it says
develop and Implement contract
management
controls special education dispute
resolution contract manage was
ineffective nhed lacked comprehensive
controls existing controls were limited
and unimplemented and monitoring was
inadequate question is is this something
that's been ongoing over the last decade
um so that might be a question we can
answer in a few minutes um page 47
uh where it says regul regulatory
non-compliance New Hampshire Ed lack
controls to ensure contractors complied
with federal and state special education
laws and rules during dispute resolution
process that's
huge and we're letting out contracts are
is there any accountability for these
contracts um are are we getting the bang
for our
51 uh on the third paragraph down or the
second paragraph starting with
Contracting Contracting and retaining
enough investigators continue to be an
issue I know we're short uh and so
Staffing over at Department of Education
um is that an area that may be something
that's been recommended by by you that
the legislature tried to maybe fund some
of these uh areas page
52 in the second last paragraph on that
P page staff acknowledged there were not
enough hearing officers to comply with
mediation scheduling requirements that
kind of linked with what I just
mentioned um so I I get that on page
57 I'm almost done here uh the first
bullet New Hampshire
Ed did not establish procedures to
identify and disclose conflicts of
interest for five of six dispute
resolution
processes so the people are being hired
to do these investigate now is there a
conflict in terms of um uh the
contractor accepting and conducting
these processes is there a conflict with
that particular um uh person
investigating that contractor with the
the with the uh being too close I guess
to some of these
situations um then I I guess a big one
for me is on page
61 right on the top of the page there
last sentence without sufficient cost
tracking and controls New Hampshire Ed
could not ensure state and federal funds
were consistently expended
appropriately that's accountability for
the dollars that we're appropriating and
the next sentence down under inadequate
contractor payment controls contractor
payment controls were inadequate and
insufficient to reduce fraud risk
there's a word that we don't want to get
fraud I don't know if I'm getting close
to where you ended I had other areas um
but I'll stop right there so those are
all areas which some captured my
attention really quickly here and it
kind of Echoes what Senator Reagan was
after and we were after i' just like to
know where are we now in terms of
addressing some of these really severe
significant
issues is that a question for LBA or is
that question for believe that's for the
Department if you'd like them to talk
okay other concerns or questions
representative Cornell Thank you I it
keeps saying management and I don't is
there a definition of management or who
is management or uh we Define management
as staff with the authority to supervise
and make policy and procedural decisions
on the operations so uh literal
management positions all the way up to
the
commissioner okay so it would be the
commissioner assigning people to those
positions and they are supposed to do
what the implementation who's
responsible for implementing the
requirements okay yeah thank you perent
would talk thank you chairman good
morning I'm sure you have all his
questions in order an answer right yeah
okay um but thank you uh my question
goes back uh following along represent
lad's uh comment but mine simpler one
question or two um in the executive
summary when you offered the uh issues
at the beginning
um I fig page five or
something sure what number it was but um
P one page one there you go thanks um
and you outlined in your chart on page
five the uh issues and the concurrence
and non-c concurrence my question is um
what happens next to those
recommendations and who's responsible
for that so our the lb's responsibility
ends here um there is an executive order
for the Department to report on the
progress of our audits I believe it's a
90 I'm not positive the timeline but
they have to be reported to the
Department of administrative services
and there's incremental reporting after
that
during the fiscal committee meeting
where we released this report uh they
also re required Christine corly update
quarterly updates on the progress of the
resolution of these
findings okay go ahead thank you
chairman so the the uh 45 days or the
90-day followup direction is that under
that March 15th date that you said that
or the rep was
released when the clock when's this
clock start again yes once the report
publicly release the clock starts okay
thank you thank you CH you're welcome
further questions yes representative
cascaden thank you um uh my question is
since this report is looking at data
from
2017 has there been other legislative
audits done before or is this the very
first time on this
topic than oh when you do an audit then
you break it out into different topics
Okay so yes on dispute resolution so we
uh we referenced a couple audits in our
glossery okay there's a 1991 in a
1999 performance audit they weren't
directly for dispute resolution but they
did have certain findings that were
relevant to this audit but this is the
first time that we did an audit specific
to dispute resolution processes okay
thank you yeah further questions from
the committee yes represent leus
thank
you is there a
person that is in charge of
overseeing these specific this
particular department or this particular
you know dispute resolution is there one
person who's responsible for making sure
this all
works so for the operational part it is
spread out across the department
depending on which dispute resolution
process uh monitoring is also part of
that that's also a different part of the
department um which is one of the
reasons why we have observation number
three because of how it's spread out
across the department So currently there
is not a person that's responsible not
for all six okay thank um I will say
that five out of the six that fall under
one manager
supervision there are multiple staff
members involved across the department
however okay yeah thank you representa
Terry uh thank you you uh I'd just like
to drill down a bit more on the question
with respect to um
management
um what uh I presume that would would
include two classifications of people if
you will um those who are appointees
such as the commissioner and full-time
perhaps career employees of the
department if that is
correct by the nodding of your head I
or no or
words I would like to follow up so
management will consist of the
appointees and classified and
unclassified okay could could you
characterize the the number or the
percentage with respect to
appointees uh as a percentage of the
total and the full-time employees as a
percentage of the total we talking like
5% 95 2080 could you since you're
Auditors I would assume that you're
going to have some kind of fix on that
we don't you don't know we don't how
many are employees and you just know
their management you don't Staffing
analysis you don't know okay so for the
purpose of this audit we didn't would
you say that it's likely that that most
of the the folks in the management
category are full-time career employees
rather than appointees I believe that's
true thank you thank you other questions
represent Miler thank you and thank you
for being here um on the the face of it
this appears to be a pretty damning
report as it relates to the study that
you've done the one question I guess I
have and we'll get into more questions
I'm sure later but this has been a focus
upon the
department um what in your review what
role does the local school district play
if any as it relates to this report so
we have not quite gotten to that point
yet there is uh the there are monitoring
and enforcement responsibilities the
department has over local educational
agencies or schools uh which an
observation in this does address their
role limited to dispute resolution
process requirements so is there a
followup and and the rest of your study
that will then cover that particular
area I'm sorry
right our office is currently performing
another audit of the special education
program that audit will cover uh
everything other than
this thank so there is a larger audit
that's ongoing right now yes this that's
correct we were on this one right here
was due process and that's where we
ended up going the direction of the
special education
Advocate uh being separated from HHS and
d uh doe uh but we we did not go into
the other areas of special education
you know the whole gamut we didn't do
that yes just just another another point
was you you mentioned the concern about
the the loss of federal funds as a
result of what you found in this report
can you expand a little bit more on that
please sure so for receiving a grant
Award of federal funds agencies have to
develop internal controls um for to
ensure that the funds are being expended
appropriately and in accordance with the
requirements of those
grants uh it happens to be that those
internal control standards are the same
exact standards that we use to audit
agencies and not so much for those three
state processes that were developed but
for the three that are federally
required we found those internal
controls were not in place according to
the requirements of receiving Grant
Awards that's where we find um they're
potentially a risk at losing Federal
funding if Federal monitors or the
agency comes in and determines they are
also not sufficient internal controls
just as a follow again on that point do
you have any contact with the federal
agencies or is that clearly within the
purview of the department we do not yeah
okay thank you further questions
represent
Damon thank you Mr chair thank you for
being here and for your work I have two
questions so one you referenced that
although there wasn't a prior due
process audit that there were some
findings in the 1991 and I think you
said 1999 that were
relevant were those findings addressed
or are they still present concerns we uh
noted them in observations as
appropriate normally we put an appendix
at the back to show the progress of the
uh previous audit findings however since
these are over 30 years old Federal
requirements and state requirements have
changed so much then we didn't take them
for one for one so where we found
long-standing issues
from these findings we noted them in
those
observations okay and then if I may um
and the audit that is ongoing looking at
the rest of special education Beyond due
process when would that be expected to
be
reported we don't expect that audit to
be completed until um closer towards the
end of this calendar
year man and does that audit represent
the same time period as
this that audit I believe is just for
one fisal year which one is that correct
Jay
yeah that manager is not here at the
moment so he would be able to answer but
I think it's just for one fiscal year do
we know which one
20 22 so it overlaps with this yes thank
you further questions represent luno
thank you very much Mr chair along the
um the same line as as the question from
representative Damon oh and thank you
very much for uh for being here and and
leading us through this this very
detailed report um following um on
representative Damon's first question
I'm jumping ahead a little bit into a um
um a statement that you make on page 7
70 under regulatory but I think it
applies under management control as well
um in the last paragraph and it refers
to the two audits that um represent
Damon was was just referring to but then
it goes on to say nhed reportedly had no
plans to address recommendations in a
relevant report released in November
2021 so much more recent than than the
earlier reports
uh by the committee to study special
education dispute resolution opt options
and the burden of proof and doe process
hearings so the the the the com the
statement here is nhed reportedly had no
plans to address the
recommendations um I was wondering did
you get to a why um they've got no no
plans to address some um recommendations
that were clearly relevant to this area
right so when we say no plans it's more
of that internal control where there
should be procedures in place to address
recommendations from uh evaluations and
audit findings that's what we mean by no
plans they didn't have procedures in
place to ensure recommendations and
audit findings went through a specific
process to uh remediate those issues
um so that's why there why they hadn't
established it's a procedural control
that just wasn't
established it wasn't that they didn't
want to remediate findings it's the
procedures were in place to ensure that
happened yeah further questions
represent Celli thank you thank you very
much for being here and going through
this um with us um follow up on a couple
of um points made um I think
representative Miler was uh talking
about the costs and um a note on page 63
under your recommendations uh develop
and Implement procedures to effectively
determine costs associated with special
ed dispute resolution processes for
staff contractors and
stakeholders um refer that back to also
um I think there been references to um
complexity of due process um
Alternatives and we've heard about that
um in testimony on uh prior legislation
that we've dealt with this year um would
you um agree that complexity and um in
some places ad hoc
rules um that uh are actually encouraged
at the local level um add to the
complexity and possibly add to the costs
for um the department and
also you highlight um stakeholder costs
which we have heard about for since I've
been here um so is there a complexity
Factor associated with costs yes and I
believe we mentioned that in part of the
observation is that uh it's one of the
major barriers that stakeholders
reported which
either some I reported that they would
have to hire legal help because of that
um even as Auditors we found it very
complex to understand these requirements
uh the ad hoc rules definitely
contributed
um with the complexity because many of
these requirements weren't known to
everybody without being formally
established in laws and rules um which I
believe we do may have a little section
on that as a cost to stakeholders those
barriers yes
um so I I think it's mentioned in here
also um that um we have I'm sorry thank
you um we have the rules we have state
law and federal law and in some cases
never the twain shall meet um and that
um you know we do have charts and I'm
I'm getting a chart um made copies of
for everybody um of where we have rules
that go above and beyond state or
federal law which in my mind um is two
problems
um possibly the complexity is involved
there um as well but as a legislator I
have problems when we have rules that go
beyond um laws that have been passed
either federally or here in New
Hampshire um because there is um little
legislative input other other than Jael
car who maybe aren't um totally up to um
the level of knowledge um that we we
correcting um this term but
um is that um maybe over
regulation on the part of the state in
not in compliance with state or federal
law is that part of the complexity
issue so you're asking if having the
standards in excess oh is that over
relation the the rules in excess of of
law we did look at the uh the rules that
were noted on that chart I I think we're
skipping a little bit ahead yeah I'm
sorry yeah no and observation number I
think observation number 10 references
that standards and excess chart what we
actually found was that not everything
that should be included was included on
that chart um we did not have an opinion
or conclude on whether those standards
were appropriately in excess
we decided that was up for the
department and the legislature to
decide thank you further questions or
shall we go on represent Woodcock and
then then we'll go on for further
presentation thank you I just I want to
go back I want to make sure I'm clear on
this on the page 567 that the 20
recommendations now that's the summary
recommendations that came out of as
audit yes okay and when I asked uh what
the next step was and you said there's
quarterly
updates on those things does this
committee or who gets those who follow
legislatively where do we see the
progress how do we get that so
the yeah so the Department
administrative Services W the 45 or
90day and incremental updates those must
be submitted to the Department of
administrative services and it's posted
to transparent New Hampshire so it's
publicly posted okay and then the fiscal
committee quarterly updates will be
either inform AAL or an agenda item on
the fiscal committee
meetings okay
um that's the extent of those two okay
all right I'll probably back to that in
a minute thank you much thank you
chairman lad thank you very much FL for
than them we're going to go ahead with
it yes followup so so who has the final
oversight for the implementation and the
monitoring of the recommendations from
your report the department does we only
check in on prior Audits and the status
of Prior audits if there's an
overlapping audit topic or we're
directed to go back to that program or
agency so there's no legislative
oversight to this report it's it's
basically the department then that has
the that has the the ultimate management
of the department basically oversights
it report
correct yes and the fiscal committee can
request that the department comes back
and continue to report on the progress
of the uh findings in our reports as
well okay thank you okay I I think you
can take us further into the report here
and
then
yeah all right uh regulatory framework
chapter starts on page
observations federal law and regulations
frame the special education program and
establish procedural safeguards State
special education law impose additional
dispute resolution requirements welld
designed consistently implemented
routinely monitored and refined refined
requirements could have helped the
department ensure compliance and
Safeguard parental
rights observation number nine addresses
implementing Federal requirements the
department lack controls to ensure rules
consistently And Timely adopted Federal
procedural requirements we identified 58
Federal requirements not adopted in
rules 23 incomplete rules based on
federal requirements and 133 rules that
conflicted with Federal requirements
Federal requirements were also
inconsistently implemented followed or
enforced observation number 10 starts on
page 69 and discusses the development
and implementation of state
requirements the department lack
controls to ensure statute and rules
were effectively designed comprehensive
and clear which contributed to ad hoc Ru
making statute and rules were
inconsistent with one another and at
times did not reflect Federal
requirements state requirements were
also inconsistently implemented or
enforced resulting in
non-compliance statute did not always
include Authority for two statute did
not include Authority for two of the six
dispute resolution processes available
legislative action may be required to
fully address our recommendations to
improve State dispute resolution
requirements including for ensuring the
department has authority to implement
all
processes observation number 11 starts
on page
73 the observation discussed is
complying with the administrative
procedure act RSA 54
41A rules were unnecessarily complex
which was a long-standing issue several
chapters and sections of rules contained
requirements for dispute resolution
resolution procedures however it was not
clear which rules applied and when many
dispute resolution practices and
requirements were informally developed
over time without appropriate adoption
of rule we identified 472 ad hoc rules
in our review of requirements and 80 ad
hoc rules and a separate review of 23
Department guides manuals and other
published materials
starting on page 20 it's starting on
page 77 observation number 12 addresses
developing policies and procedures the
department lacked written policies and
procedures for training monitoring and
administering dispute resolution
processes lack of policies and
procedures negatively impacted
operations examples are provided on page
78 observation number 13 starts on page
80 the observation addresses improve the
department website guides and manuals to
ensure requirements are publicly
available understandable and effectively
communicated to stakeholders
stakeholders reported Department
published information was difficult to
understand unclear overwhelming and it
was hard to find specific information we
identified 339 issues with the website
guides and manuals examples are in the
81 observation number 14 starts on page
82 and discusses providing training and
education to stakeholders to ensure
expectations and requirements are
understood and effectively
communicated School representatives were
not always aware of certain requirements
and some stakeholders reported a need
for training and education however the
department did not provide proactive
training and education for dispute
resolution requirements and did not
identify groups of stakeholders which
would benefit from receiving training
and
education this concludes the second
chapter if there are any questions at
this point are there questions from the
committee regarding this this
chapter
uh I I I'd like to go back to page 71
please and there's two sets of bullets
there we're using words not consistently
or clearly
implementing um the the bullet that says
report on whether leas took corrective
action to comply with federal and state
law in monitoring I would think that
that's something we we want to do after
going through a a a a due process and
then monitoring correct
action how did you assess that this was
not being done uh we were informed and
we did not find evidence that dispute
resolution monitoring was part of the
Department's program so special
education monitoring was happening but
processes and the last bullet there says
enforce a requirement that Lea's
provider written report within 90 days
of a due process hearing describing Etc
um so that didn't come in either from
the laa to the the department correct
that was another requirement that we
found was not formally delegated to
ensure it was being
implemented okay and and that is that a
department issue or is that a local
school district issue the department is
responsible for ensuring the local
schools follow requirements thank you
yes representative
Cornell so to get back to representative
chairman lad's question did do the elas
know that they're supposed to do that it
sounds like there's not a lot of
communication to the leas of what what
they're responsible for right so we did
ask I'm not I do not remember if we
asked this specific question but we did
ask certain procedural requirements in
our local education survey and we found
some of those many schools are not aware
of those requirements I'm not sure if
this was one of those that we asked
about thank you y and I'll follow up
with does doe I read in the report and I
don't know where but many of this is
done because the staff member At Doe has
a historical background of how things
did occur is not necessarily written
down in a book it's just I have the
history of this process and then folks
are changing or leaving their position
and you lose that history is that sort
of what's going on here that we we have
uh you know it's understood by this
person this person leaves and the whole
process leaves with that person right
and uh so our policies and procedures
observation addresses that as well a lot
of the institutional knowledge was
reliant on staff who had been there for
not that many years uh there was one
tene staff member in of the six who were
part of the dispute resolution processes
who was also nearing retirement so there
was a huge risk of knowledge loss at
that
Point further yes represent
cordelli thank you I uh I think that a
lot of this section um relates to what
you talked about
overlap um with the leas and um I recall
that uh when we first started the
performance audit and looking at the
scope of work several of us um submitted
um issues that you weren't looking at
the local level when looking at do due
process you were just looking at um the
state level and so uh you know I'm very
glad to hear that um I knowing how broad
an issue special education is that there
is a separate audit that will um address
some of these areas and hopefully some
of this overlap because um again on page
71 where um uh chairman lad was talking
about it says state law required leas to
notify the department when a parent had
rejected an IEP placement identification
or evaluation and again we've heard
testimony on that issue um uh previously
uh this year and um I I think that will
be something I want to bring up when we
get um into another step maybe the next
section of the uh of the uh audit
review but I I think that that's um
troubling um for both the state and for
the parents um when they've
rejected um let's say an IEP
recommendation and they're in limbo in
many cases um so I I think that some of
these um might be easily corrected um
and that's my hope and um we'll keep
watch on it thank
you I'm going to slip back to page 67
it's in the sort of in the same ballpark
that represent cordelli is speaking to
there's
uh where it says additionally comma
rules the last bullet there struck my
attention here it says did not establish
a process for parents to open due
process hearings to the public despite
being a federally established parental
right um so it gets back to my my
curiosi is do the local school districts
know the we we supposedly have directors
that are on top of uh directing special
education at the local level but are
they knowledgeable of all these
requirements that are in
[Music]
idea as I stated before we did ask about
certain requirements uh unfortunately
because the local processes were not
monitored
or reviewed during the processes much of
what we would like to know if was
happening at the local level was not
auditable at the state level um however
that's why we have the training and
education observation is because we did
find that there are certain requirements
that local education agencies
specifically stated they were unaware of
and would like more training
um so I hope that answers your question
is this responsibility the department or
responsibility of the local school
board it's the responsibility of the
department to make sure the requirements
are being followed and in accordance
with how they should be
followed I I think it's both but it
starts with the Department thank you
further questions rips on my one on that
point did you have an assessment of
excuse me did you you have an assessment
of the
relationship between the department and
the leas across the state I mean is
there is there a close working
relationship between the department and
the local school districts is there an
estrangement between the two of them I
mean how does what is the communication
issues that are between the two so for
this small of a scope we did do the
appendix D has the educational agency
survey um wasn't a great result that 22%
of the leas filled it out but the
results are generally positive there
were some certain areas like I said they
expressed more Assistance or better
procedures um but as far as the
relationship between the leas and the
department itself I it was pretty
positive thank you yep thank
you you represent luno so so thanks very
much Mr chair th this isn't directly Rel
related to regulatory or or management
but sort of um just just in general was
wondering if you got any sense as to the
um the percentage of of uh of complaints
that that arose from students attending
uh Public Schools compared to uh to
Charter Schools or if there was the you
know um because because the um the Lea
the public school is responsible right
for special education services at at uh
at the chartered um schools as well but
just wondering if there was maybe a a
proportionate percentage of the
complaints coming from Charters or or
disproportionate so we didn't include
the demographic data in our scope of
file reviews um I'm sure the department
might have a little bit more information
on that okay thanks thank you yes
representative uh
Pell thank you and thank you for taking
my question um what is the federal
oversight of the implementation of these
requirements because we're talking about
the um the Department's requirements to
implement them but what how does the
federal government get involved in um
overseeing the insurance that these
regulations are
implemented I'll let the dep Department
continue on that answer but uh as far as
what we saw in the federally required
reporting it's very limited to certain
for dispute resolution it's a very very
very very small portion of oversight um
limited to certain targets or
percentages of completion or Su success
rates or which is resulting in a formal
agreement for some of these processes um
I'm not sure what else is part of that
because we didn't look at that process
but the department will be able to speak
to
that I can also just add to that um the
the state of New Hampshire um has a an
annual audit of uh the state's federal
assistance programs that's an annual
audit of U Federal
expenditures um so KPMG the Statewide
auditor performs that audit and there
would be findings in that audit if there
were any issues that came up uh with the
special education program that audit is
year
you our performance and enforcement
chapter starts in page 87 and contains
six
observations effective Performance
Management helps provide a basis for
making objective data informed decisions
well-controlled enforcement procedures
could increase the likelihood outcomes
are efficiently and effectively
achieved observation 15 starts on page
88 which addresses developing and
implementing Performance Management
control
the department did not have sufficient
and accurate data to evaluate efficiency
and effectiveness of dispute resolution
processes there was no department-wide
tracking or monitoring of dispute
resolution processes to identify Trends
and address issues available dispute
resolution processes outputs were
limited unreliable and primarily focused
on federal reporting requirements while
other quantifiable goals objectives and
targets were not developed resulting in
non-compliance with State reporting
requirements observation number 16
starts on page 93
the observation discusses monitoring and
enforcing local educational agency
compliance with dispute resolution
requirements the department did not
monitor compliance and Implement
required enforcement actions for
non-compliance without effective
oversight the department could not
provide reasonable Assurance the rights
of children with disabilities and their
parents were
protected observation number 17 starts
on page 98 and addresses developing
controls over dispute resolution
agreements the department lacked
controls to ensure agreements were
compliant with requirements and
implemented as required public
transparency was compromised and parents
were inappropriately burdened with
enforcement
responsibilities we also found dispute
resolution agreements to be generally
unregulated resulting in stakeholders
expressing concerns about the use of
certain terms and conditions parents
reported fears of violating agreements
because of these terms and conditions
this directly affected legislators the
Departments and our ability to obtain
quality feedback for process
improvements from these
stakeholders we make a recommendation
for the legisl to consider reviewing
usage of agreements and determine
whether State policy changes regulating
aspects of agreements would benefit
participants and improve dispute
resolution
processes observation number 18 starts
on page
101 the observation addresses developing
a Public Communication System to ensure
complaints are fully addressed and
external Communications are timely and
effective we found the department did
not establish and publicize clear lines
of communication including instructions
and laws rules and guidance for
stakeholders ERS to formally file
requests and complaints allegations were
not always fully addressed and
non-compliance with certain notice and
posting requirements occurred
legislative action may be required to
address our recommendation to update and
ensure dispute resolution process filing
information is
accurate observation number 19 starts on
page
105 the observation addresses records
and data management controls reliable
records and data are necessary for
measuring performance supporting
decisions and evaluating risk records
management control should be developed
in accordance with relevant laws and
rules we found the department lacked
records management policies and
procedures resulting in records being
incomplete missing or untimely provided
to management at times records lack
sufficient documentation and were not
auditable observation number 20 starts
on page
110 and discusses improving management
of confidential
records the department lack controls to
ensure deletion of personally
identifiable information from due
process hearing decisions was conducted
in accordance with Federal requirements
Additionally the Department's ability to
effectively manage two dispute
resolution processes was limited in part
due to unclear and conflicting record
restrictions in state law legislative
action may be required to address a
recommendation to remove conflicting
record requirements which hinder
effective management of mediation and
neutral conference
processes appendix a c and d are at the
back of the report appendix a is our
scope objective in methodology appendix
C is our our special education dispute
resol resolution parent survey and
appendix D is our dispute resolution
local educational agency survey this
concludes the third chapter and the rest
of the report if there are any questions
at this point yes represent cordelli
um we've talked about um
controls
tracking um and here on page 89 I think
um
being a former it guy um hits me and
that it says
um proc due process timelines not
sufficiently tracked in the database for
reporting requirements staff
acknowledged the database was outdated
and insufficient tracking needs um we
again we've talked about this a little
bit um and for years I've heard about um
the database and I forget the acronym um
Ness and something or maybe that's a TV
channel I don't know um but um the uh I
I took the opportunity to you know just
glance through um and found at least
four or five um specific special
education uh
databases um one with power school a
module of power school which a lot of
districts um use I believe um and uh
Connecticut just three or four years ago
had a system developed for them and I've
got I think the majority of the
functional specifications that they use
for that um but I think that uh a new
system uh to manage special
education that would be used by all
districts not just some of them U I even
heard just recently that um maybe the
current system has some um abilities in
it for tracking that haven't been used
so you know I I think what we need is
someone to come in and do an
evaluation of the current system what um
what is outdated what functionality is
there what functionality is not being
used and then look at that um in
comparison to some of these other
systems that are available that I think
would help immensely in terms of
controls and tracking which are two of
the major um areas covered in in this um
report um so that's you number one for
me but um maybe number two and three um
on page
99 um and this this I've let you know
you have your legislative um uh to-do
list well I've got my own um and one of
those comes on page
99 where it says some parents reported
feeling forced or pressured to sign a
agreements and um left no their options
to obtain necessary Ser services and
fearful of
retaliation um we've heard that from
parents in the past um and that's um
that's on my legislative to-do list um
um then on the next page 100 um we
suggest the legislator legislature
consider reviewing usage agreements
including
non-disclosure and non-disparagement
clauses
uh to determine whether policy changes
are needed um and
um uh I I would say yes um um and I
worked on legislation for that um so um
you know we'll see what happens in the
future but uh certainly there are uh for
mediation and some of the due process
hearing um processes there are federal
requirements in terms of
non-disclosure but in many cases from
what I've heard from parents
non-disclosure agreements are
required as a beginning step to go
forward with the mediation or something
which is not required under federal law
um so I think that's another area where
we can have um an impact um with
legislation um in the next session if
not with uh um non gerain amendments uh
on Senate
bills thank you if I could just clarify
the databases that we're talking about
for dispute resolution are separate from
okay the special education I believe the
acronym is nessus New Hampshire special
education information system so that
system handles all other aspects of
special education or most and so this is
a this is a their separate it's a
separate database there's multiple uh
spreadsheets and databases as part of
this yeah so am I correct in my thinking
that maybe one comprehensive system to
combine some of those spreadsheets and
miscellaneous other um uh data sources
might uh help with tracking and controls
I believe the department uh I'm not sure
if they put it in their recommendation
or their response specifically but I
believe the department was looking into
other options right and I see one was a
Salesforce that's in use
um by other departments and um my big
notation there was no um we need
education yes represent luno thank you
very much Mr chair just sort of a
process question does the um does the
state need to make its own state laws in
order for the Department of Education to
enact rules to comply with um with
can you rephrase that a little bit so so
just as representative cordelli was
talking about there's federal laws and
there's state laws yes and and uh the
rule making the um that each that all
the Departments do basically have an
underpinning by in Statute in state law
but I'm wondering can the
can the department conduct Ru making uh
to with using a federal law as its
underpinning yes so for the state
complaint process there's actually no
state laws for state complaints it goes
strict uh straight from federal to the
rules okay and that's fine um some one
of some of the we still identified
issues between connecting those two but
you don't need to connect with the state
law between those two okay and and and
and I I know it's in here somewhere and
you probably talk about so followup are
there are there is there additional Ru
making that that you're recommending
that the department of Ed do in order to
be compliant with federal law yes uh so
the federal requirements observation
number
nine if I have that right um that's most
of the areas where we talk about the
federal requirements and the ru making
align with each other okay thank you
very much
yes represent whitcock thank you going
back no no U but that the 20 I just want
to make sure I understand this report I
looked at it I read it through the
executive summ twice and I sort of scan
this so the the reports that you talked
about going through follow up at each
part of the executive summary they just
elaborate what was in the executive
summary right okay so uh repr leas a
while ago uh asked the question about
she was trying to find out I think who
responsible for what uh and then we
talked about additional uh special
education uh ongoing or soon to go uh
another audit so I'm looking at I'm
looking at um page 25 going back just to
the table
organization so and I'm probably
Incorrect and that's why I'm going to
ask you to help me here I'm assuming
that when it says offer the commission
you're talking about the commissioner of
Education alot right okay that's that's
the big guy okay so in terms of this
which only covers two years 20 to
22 but is
um
uh huge in terms of the implications of
of lack of oversight in and Regulatory
workare now am I am I looking at the
left-and side the governance unit that's
where all this falls under and on the
right hand side is going to be the
additional audit is that how we look at
that right
so
these these two sides are both dispute
resolution yes the majority of the
special education audit is going to fall
under the division of learner support
Bureau of special education support
that's for most of the next audit the
next a okay so so you almost can write a
line down this this a on the left hand
side next a on the right hand side so
some of the some of the issues that
representative Mila had and cordelli
were talking about local school boards
uh in their their interaction and those
types of reference are going to be more
right hand side report right that hasn't
come yet but so all these um
extraordinary issues only for just the
last two years not only how long it
could have been beyond that all on the
left-hand side for the most
part that right so yes so four uh five
of the six processes are on the left
side right one of the processes and
monitoring responsibilities are on the
right side yeah yes okay and may just
fall okay thank you so I'm looking
at what the part think represent luno
refering to but I have a high time
understanding is well over 75% of your
um 20
recommendations the department concurs
that they're
accurate and then there's some
partially how does that
happen that you have an exhaustive
report that identifies 20 major flaws
ongoingly on a daily basis
and the respond
concur it depends sometimes uh there may
be disagreement with the facts in our
observation and not specifically the
recommendation uh sometimes the
department may feel that the
recommendations are not feasible to
implement um
so if they're not feasible to implement
they just don't do
it it may be it depends again I'm not
speaking directly for the Department
okay but um if it sometimes if they may
not be able to implement because they
feel there's some kind of statutory
restrictions or resource restrictions
and it's really up to them to determine
whether it's cost effective and makees
sense to change those or request more
resources so right one more simp yes go
ahead thank you the last one this
nothing to do with this can you tell me
how many hours the staff invested in
doing this audit your staff your
department we have that number but not
on us
huh we right we we do have that number
we don't have it with us today though so
i' have to go back curious It's so
exhausted was curious how many hours of
okay it's a lot of effort yeah I just it
seems like it I started this audit in
March
2022 so two years ago
yes and I had two to three staff in and
out during that time period wow okay hey
thank you thank you chairman live thank
you paage uh when you're doing this
audit I'm looking at page 111
uh and looking at
contractors and processes that have or
have not been filed IE reference
fura uh using their own private email to
address confidential issues dealing with
the
IEP um uh in your looking at contractors
and because it's been mentioned
throughout here uh is there a process
you found that's fairly consistent that
there's criteria is spelled out there's
a a handbook available to contractors
what their responsibilities are they
shall report they shall do this this and
this is that available to the
contractors so it depended on the
contractor the hearing and the process
so the hearing officers we found who
were responsible for four out of the six
processes did have more robust
requirements and a handbook however we
also found that the handbook was not
required and the information Within it
was not being enforced so so there's no
oversight the management control part
correct yes yeah repes
luno so thank you very much Mr chair
along those same lines and um and sort
of along lines of what representative
Woodcock was was talking
about there there there seems to be a a
lack of of and the there's consistency
in the report but I'm talking about in
respon from the Department to to some of
the findings and recommendations in the
in the report for example um on uh on
page 68 under regulatory framework where
the um where the department um concurs
only in part with the
recommendations uh the department goes
on to say the governance unit has
processes to help ensure that it
complies with federal and state
timelines and assess where these
procedures can be can be developed so
that they're more comprehensive and
formal so they say that I'm I'm and I'm
that that seems to be where they
disagree with either your finding a
recommendation but then on page 89 so
that's in regulatory framework and then
on page 89 under performance and
enforcement um um one of the findings is
so this is in the middle of page 89 we
reviewed a judgmental sample of 12 due
process complaint cases out of 115
uh from fiscal years 20 to 22 we found
due process timelines were not
sufficiently tracked in the database so
here we've got an example of of where
the where the the the department
disagrees with a finding under
regulatory framework saying that they've
got the process in place but then under
under performance and execution clearly
they don't have the process in place and
and I I guess this isn't so much of a a
question but but to you but maybe a
question to the committee do we need to
do a
crosswalk um between regulatory per and
and performance and management controls
to to see where maybe the Department's
response is inconsistent with findings
um found in other sections of the uh the
audit so this a question to you Mr
chair I want to be very careful not to
start into the executive
responsibilities and and what our
responsibility is of course we write law
and we are looking to see if is that law
being adhered to right now um and I I'm
concerned my concern I guess and maybe
you mentioned this the fiscal as well if
not I will um I understand approximately
this is an approximate figure a huge
maybe 80% of our staff over a doe are
paid through federal dollars and we
appropriate the dollars for the other
side now I I might be off percentage one
way or the other and my concerns are is
that in your looking at this have you
found that there's been an effort to
comply with federal law and state law
however we're limited by the number of
Staff which we have over there that are
dealing with due process here from both
the federal and the state perspective
uh so did you see that you know if in
looking at all these recommendations
which there's so many in there and I see
responses also from the department but
do we have the staff to do what we need
to do I let the department answer that
when they come up uh observation number
three though does include some of our
concerns about the current Staffing
levels uh and the workloads which is one
of the reasons why we recommend I
believe we recommend there's should be
an valuation of responsibilities for
these
processes okay thank you further
committee are we at the bottom line
yet we're set if you're set
then okay are there any further
questions of the
LBA nice thank you very much thank you
thank you for a thorough job appreciate
it the department are you willing
to maybe respond to some of our
questions which we had or issues that
up you need another chair for all of you
don't
okay is the red light on there you go
there you go thank you very much good
morning Christine Brennan from the
Department of Education Deputy
Commissioner um thank you for having us
and we appreciate the opportunity to
address the concerns um raised regarding
the department of education's dispute
resolution process as outlined in the
recent auditor report um we want to
thank the Auditors um for their hard
work on this report and our robust
conversations to improve the process
were helpful and in they were helpful
insights to consider on New Hampshire
Department of Education is committed to
ensuring that the rights of children
with disabilities and their families are
protected and we believe that early
resolution of disputes will lead to
positive outcomes for children as
someone who has dedicated their career
to the field of Education I have had the
privilege of sitting through countless
individualized education program
meetings these experiences have given me
firsthand insight to the challenges
faced by families navigating the special
education process which is designed to
ensure that children with
disabilities receive appropriate
services and supports tailored to their
individual needs this process can often
feel daunting especially for parents who
are navigating it for the first time I
also understand the need to provide
ongoing professional development to leas
so that they are clear about the
statutory requirements which servicing
children with special needs each member
brings their own perspective and
expertise and experience to the table T
which can sometimes lead to
disagreements and misunderstandings when
an IEP team is not functioning
collaboratively students lose out in
learning opportunities the department is
committed to making significant strides
in this regard using the audit as a tool
we want this to be our North Star uh we
have implemented various measures aimed
at streamlining the process and
providing clar guidance um and ensuring
that all parties feel valued and heard
the Department of Education is committed
to transparency and accountability for
our operations we are actively working
to improve public a access to
information regarding the special ed
education dispute resolution um we've
been collaborating with st stakeholders
to create a parent guide guidance
document our staff is bringing all of
the parent guidance documents the
policies as well as of our our audit to
a training and work session with the
national Center of systematic
Improvement um they are a national
technical assistance organization and
they funded by the federal office of
special education to assist specifically
with the um Estates in developing
policies and procedures um and to ensure
alignment with the idea and our state
regulations they will also assist us
with formalizing our process in a
comprehensive manner while while
ensuring that we are compliant with
state and federal law monitoring
enforcement and compliance is a top
priority recently we changed our
monitoring practices our dedicated team
monitors um performances of schools
conducts systematic audits audits
incorporating information from our staff
in governance to take action solve
problems and address any instances of
non-compliance we see the need to
improve our collaboration with
stakeholders and bring some of our 20 uh
some of our processes to the 21st
century to address changes and
challenges um we plan on using
technology and we're research searching
ways to make our system more automated
and give families more access and
guidance about the dispute resolution
process in the options that they have as
we move forward the department is deeply
committed to safeguarding the rights of
children with disabilities and with
their parents our procedures are
designed with stringent adherence to
federal and state laws governing special
education any deviations or perceived
shortcomings will be addressed promptly
and Contin with um continuous
Improvement efforts um I also know that
we need to be working together uh to
prame some of this effective management
some of these initiatives will need to
be done legislatively currently we have
HB
443 and HB 480 um 443 is about the I um
indiv individualize um facilitated is
that the right
terminology no that one's the Neal oh
that's the neutral conference one where
we need to embed some of our practices
into another dispute resolution process
and then 1480 is for the um facilitated
IEP person um in this current
legislative session we are direct
responses to the audit findings and we
look forward to continuing to work
collaboratively with this legislative
body to address the concerns that were
raised in the audit the department also
looks forward to working collaboratively
with stakeholders including parents
Educators hearing offic ERS
investigators IEP
facilit facilitators and we can continue
to improve the dispute resolution
process ensure that every child receives
a support they need to succeed in
conclusion while we appreciate the
audits finding um the audit's findings
as an opportunity for reflection and
Improvement we maintain that the New
Hampshire Doe's management of the
special education dispute resolution
process is aligned with our commitment
to serving the best interests of
children with disabilities and their
families and we embrace the opportunity
to improve we remain dedicated to
continuous Improvement and welcome
ongoing collaboration with stakeholders
to further enhance our Pro practices I
am confident that we can create a more
inclusive and Equitable educational
landscape for all the children in New
Hampshire I have with me attorney Diane
Fenton who oversees our governance unit
uh Rebecca fredet who oversees a bureau
of special education and I have to say
your questions were fantastic so I look
forward to answering some of these and
making sure that we have a really clear
understanding of what's Happening Here
in the field and in our office thank you
very much are there questions yes
representa
Hall thank you I'm thank you for being
here uh I'm just curious what was the
overall reaction with the doe when you
saw this audit were you like shocked
were you expecting those
results so I think um that I I was a
little bit shocked because I do feel
like we have Pro processes and
procedures in place but I recognize that
they need to be more for formalized in a
comprehensive way that was my
gut thank you representative Miler thank
you Mr chair and and thank you Dr Bren
for being here it's nice to see you here
thank you nice to see you too I have a
couple questions how many staff do you
have in the special ed Department
dealing with the host kogal here that
we're talking about investig ations
followup Etc then my first question is
how many staff do you have to cover this
department so this I'm just going to
give a general um not a specific number
to help you understand so in our
governance unit people that are
dedicated to the dispute resolution
process which is separate from Rebecca's
office because we really want to keep
the Integrity of the process um
separated from what they're doing at
special education to to maintain
maintain good relationships in the with
our leas um so we have six is it six or
five D six people in our office and then
we contract with investigators that are
not part of our staff but they're
contracted people and I think it's
either five or six the same thing with
the um with the hearing officers and
then in Rebecca's staff I'm going to let
you do that with the monitoring because
then our office there's a mechanism
that's needed that when there is a
dispute we send it or any complaints or
the any of the things that you see in
our um on that table we send it to
Rebecca's office so that it can be their
made aware of um and there's ways that
we need to strengthen that process but
so that she can go out and monitor the
elas
M thank you very much thank you
representative Miler um we do we have
one staff member who does the IEP
facilitation um so she arranges all of
the facilitators who go to meetings with
parents and um districts and that's part
of her position and then we do have
monitoring we have currently nine people
who do monitoring um we are just barely
started a new monitoring process we were
in our first round of this monitoring
and we are in the process of hiring one
individual who will Who the most of
their focus will be on um the
information that comes from the
governance unit and then what the the
federal government has called um due
diligence reviews so if we hear a
complaint or we hear something from a a
a an outside entity we have to do our
due diligence and we have to determine
if it's a credible allegation so that is
something that we've been developing and
it currently is posted right now so
we're in the process of fulfilling that
position so monitoring I have people but
specifically for these things it would
be about two and a half people if you
wanted to one and a half people that you
want to look in my in my department
followup please second part
is representative lad earlier said that
about 80 5% of the department staff is
funded through federal funds
specifically as it relates to your
department how much federal funds comes
in and are those funds directed at the
at Staffing or is some of that funds
directed to other department staff not
related to special ed needs so all of
our funding is either directed straight
to the districts um we received $54
Million last Year from the federal
government I we have not gotten our
allocation for this coming year so I I
don't know what that is um but a
majority of that funding goes directly
to districts and we um provide that to
them based on an allocation based on
their um this their child count and um
free and reduced lunch there's a it's a
formula that I could go get somebody
else to tell you um but we do provide
most of it to them and then the
remaining money comes to us for
discretionary funding or administrative
funding and then from um and then from
the state because I think that was your
other question we receive to to process
and run special education we received
$219,000 that does not include the
special education Aid money that goes
directly to districts or the court order
placement money and episod of treatment
money that all goes directly to
districts we don't use any of that money
to administer it or it's just the 219
that we use to administer um special
education special education Aid code
ordered placements and episodes of
treatment I may just clarify so your
staff is basically
funded primarily through federal funds
but the investigative piece is federal
is funded through state is that correct
So currently what we use our federal
funding for for salaries is um it pays
for 20% of my salary it pays for one
staff member who oversees um special
education Aid court ordered placements
and episodes of treatment it pays for
three clerks that come in and assist us
with processing special education Aid
because it is a very short timeline to
do that we do that between July 30th and
December 1st so they come in for just
that amount of time and then it helps to
play pay for um part of the due process
hearing costs it does not pay for all of
it it pays for just part of it thank you
represent Harry and then representative
you
um when we look at the um the
observations and we look at the
recommendations and then we note that in
the vast majority of uh the instances
that is with respect to the observations
and recommendations that the department
concurs or partially concurs um that in
and of itself I think raises some very
uh interesting
questions but um those aside for the
moment uh let me let me ask you uh two
questions one do you feel that with
respect to your
uh concurrence and partial concurrence
that you have
the the
expertise to be able to
implement the um the recommendations
that have been made at least to the
extent that you agree with
them and then secondly um a very
specific question um with regard to the
concern about unregulated agreement
contents and the
I believe you heard the extensive
comments that were made by
representative cordelli with respect to
non-disclosure agreements would would as
I note the nhed response on pages 100
and 1001 I don't find that there is uh
any content here that addresses the
concern raised in the recommendation
with respect to the non-disclosure
agreements which um very unsettling and
and troubling so if you could answer
those two questions the first is do you
believe you have the expertise to be
able to work on these uh recommendations
to the extent that you agree with them
and then number two um the lack of there
being any response um to the concern
raised about the non-disclosure
agreements in your resp Department's
response on pages 100 and 101 but would
you please address uh for us now um what
your response would be to the troubling
aspects that are raised with respect to
non-disclosure agreements thanks sure
I'm going to I'm going to start and then
I'm going to hand it over to my attorney
as well um so yes we have the expertise
and I think that for for um as far as
why we concur I um many I think that um
with with many of these audit findings
we saw how we can strengthen our program
and they found things that and unveiled
things that maybe we didn't recognize at
the time so yes we have the expertise
we'll be using Cadre another resource
we'll be using the federal um
government's technical assistance so yes
I think that we have the expertise we
have wonderful stakeholders with um um
pick and our Advocates so I feel very
confident that we can come to Great
agreement to make some of these things
happen um the second um part of your
question is sort of a two part we had
really robust conversations with the
Auditors about our authority of what we
can impose on the leas and historically
the department has not really played
that role and we have to be very careful
as we move forward because we have to
make sure that that we have the
resources and that we're not jamming up
the system so that there aren't Les
resolutions and Diana would you mind
continuing with
that
so uh good morning for the record Diana
Fenton um you know the non-disclosure
agreements has been a source of concern
for the Department um and I will
reiterate what what the Deputy
Commissioner just said is that
historically this is a role the
department has not played and it was a
refreshing robust conversation with the
Auditors when it was brought to the
Department's attention that the
department really does have more
authority to enforce at the local level
than historically we had been led to
believe that being said the department
has to be mindful as we take on that new
role that we don't open ourselves up to
any liability recognizing that these are
two-party agreements and if the
department were to suddenly impose
itself it could become a three-party
agreement and so anything we do in that
area um we need to just do it in a
mindful process and so we will be
working with the Attorney General's
office who is our legal counsel to make
sure that we don't cause unnecessary
problems but the non-disclosure
agreements is something that has
troubled not only this legislative body
but the department has been very aware
of and very concerned about and it's
nice to for the Department to know that
there are Avenues by which they can be
addressed representa
cascaden uh thank you uh Mr chair thank
thank you for being here um I I guess
I'm trying to think in Big Picture
numbers whether dispute resolution
processes have
been um more have been requested more
often or has it been pretty consistent
over the years I don't know if you know
from like say for the last 10 years or
has there been a spike of an increase or
a decrease or how are we with numbers
manageable thank you for the question um
you know it's interesting when you have
audit findings going back to 1991 and
1999 these processes have existed in
some form for a long time and they've
changed over time they have morphed um
hopefully they've morph to address the
needs that are being
seen um
I can tell you that recently we have
seen an uptick in in the numbers um and
I can certainly get you that those exact
numbers but I think part of it is an
interplay
with getting the information out to the
field to the leas to parents the
communication keeping those lines of
communication open and then being
responsive to those needs and so we have
seen an an uptick in
those just over the last I would say 3
four
years and of course you know I have to
put a caveat on everything the numbers
during the pandemic threw off those
statistics right and then we're seeing a
response to that and so when we look at
it historically we have to keep in mind
what was happening kind of society if
you will um because we have seen a
response to
that thank you repr
luno thank you very much Mr chair um uh
Dr brenon I I have um immense respect
for you and many in in the department
but I I honestly I was really surprised
by your statement because it seems to
contradict the um the the findings and
recommendations U that are laid out in
the um in the audit report and my my
question to you is um
do does does the does the department
recognize the gravity of of the findings
um that are that are in here
and how do you square statements like
calling some of these things
shortcomings um when when there are
there are you know findings in the
report that say you know things like and
this is a quote NH
could not provide reasonable Assurance
uh could could not provide reasonable
Assurance the rights of children with
disabilities and their parents were
protected and um and I I guess what I'm
asking you is is could you could you
convince me that that the department um
serious thank you so much for your
question which page did you find that on
on what response that's at the top of 94
top of 94 um so um first of all we do
take these audit reports this is my
second um audit with the LBA um working
when we had one with vocational rehab
and I find that these tools are a way
for us to improve and to get better um I
think we have 33,000 students with
special education um that have an IEP I
think when we look at some of the um
responses
you know I think that the Auditors did a
fantastic job but to only think that 25
25 people responded to the parent survey
and 25 um special Educators responded to
the audit when we have about
172 um I want to I want to make sure
that it's um that it's I just think that
that's an important fact to be looking
at this when we when we look at the
audit but I think that we want to have
continuous Improvement and we want to
make sure that we're doing that so this
is a tool to get us there I'm going to
just follow up on where Ripon luno was
and I'm I'm concerned real concerned
with this cost tracking and
controls uh with our dealing with our
contractors and on page
61 the there this was alluded to
contractor payment controls were
inadequate and insufficient to reduce
possible I won't put the word to reduce
fraud
risk then I'm looking down on the bottom
of that page two com two of these uh
contractor payment transactions two
conflicted with documentation and case
records indicating invoiced work did not
occur resulting in potentially
fraudulent
payments have we identified fraud going
on there there is no fraud that's
happening with our hearing officers um
that was a technical error and we have
already worked with our office of
Business Administration to rectify our
invoicing process and our and have had
meetings with our vendors on how um the
internal um how the invoicing must
go and I think that we are also working
with our attorney to make sure that our
contracts are better uh more well
written and do you receive the invoice
to work from the contractor for for
payment yes and we make sure that now
that the deliverables that are in the
contract are on the invoice and I can
get you a sample of the kind of invoices
or receipts documentation do that okay I
I'm I'm I'm believing what you're saying
I just just want to make sure we're not
going down a path we don't want to go
down yeah that was um I think when um
the senator asked me that was my first
reaction of oh my Lord this cannot be
true but that was the first thing that
we addressed and it was minor um and
we've reviewed many others after um the
auditor shared this information with us
so I feel 100% confident that there is
no fraud or um payments that for not for
work not being done and are those
payments paid in the fiscal year in
which they're doing this or is it
carried over where we had the issue with
the $122,000 yeah those are some of the
decisions that we are making of when the
um hearing officers need what's their
period of performance because what what
happens is some of these cases are going
on for a long time and we really want to
try to shorten that process so that kids
can get the services over a thousand
days
y yeah represent Terry and then
represent Miler it it appear to follow
on it it appears as though you you
addressed that in your response on page
64 the question that's been put to you
by chairman lad but as you as you do so
in the second in the one
two three four paragraph beginning be
bses
currently the second sentence Begins the
governance unit will modify hearing
officer
contracts can you uh since that language
has been submitted to the Auditors have
you done so and if not what's the
this so
wait yeah I see where you're I'm just I
just want to read the governance unit
will modify hearing officer contracts to
require invoice be submitted to
nhed with dot dot dot so where are you
in the process of modifying the hearing
officer contracts since this verbiage
has been included in the auditor report
have you done so are you doing so and if
you haven't completed this um this
commitment when do you expect to
complete it well the invoices have been
completed um and we're and we are we're
talking about contracts now oh the the
contracts okay the government's unit
will modify hearing officer contracts to
require so when I'm not sure of the
timeline on the contracts but they are
typically three-year contracts and so
when that contract comes up again it
would be modified to include that
language so that is something that the
the person who oversees that contract
will be working on and will be doing we
initially wanted to make sure that the
invoicing was done right away so that we
could ensure that we were getting
correct payments and there was no um
opportunity for fraud so the contracts
will be worked on oh yes so if the
contracts uh if if you're pointing to a
date in the future with respect to the
language being modified is there
anything that you can do in the room to
ensure that this is taking place before
you formalize it in contractual language
or are do we have to wait for this I
think that there's opportunity for us to
amend the contract but I believe and I
and I don't want to um give in incorrect
information but I think we are at the
very end of the three-year contract with
officers per on IA thank you Mr chair
a couple of other questions obviously
you've had a chance to review this
report Etc and one of the key issues
here obviously is uh the relationship
between the department and the local
school districts and the U knowledge of
those at the Lea level uh in
understanding what the responsibilities
are
Etc as as report throughout the report
it talks about the need to make sure
that there is an understanding of what
the respon responsibilities are so my
question to you is based upon the report
in your review uh what plans do you have
to upscale and enhance the training uh
of local uh special ed uh directors for
example to make sure that there is
compliance uh with the elements that are
in this report that's my first question
thank you that's a a great question so
um I think what um some of our plans are
for making sure that the leas understand
the dispute um resolution process we
have Partners like pic that help educate
them we do trainings ourselves around
the state which we will now enhance and
make it more systematic and um more
systematic so and in a in a policy so
that it's ensured to continuously happen
um right now we have to make sure that
our leas are telling the parents at the
meetings what their options are um and
as far as the dispute resolution happens
and what choices that they have um so
we're one of the um we met with one of
our Advocates who had um an idea of when
a we already recognize that when a
dispute or when a parent does not agree
with an IEP it's documented in nessus
and we know that there's um it's
partially reject partially you're going
to have to get the terminology correct
but we have this information we have
this data we can run reports um and so
now we need to look at a systematic
approach of how often do we run the
report how many parents what districts
are maybe continuously having dispute
resolution processes we have to start
analyzing that kind of data and then
coming up with a good implementation
process um so that the leas understand
the process and the parents do two two
follow-ups please so do you have a
schedule for these training are these
are these episodic based upon your
definition of what needs to be done at a
particular School District level so is
there a training schedule for this that
you've you've developed or what so we've
always had trainings but I think again
we need to formalizing and when we were
doing the trainings before it was kind
of um reactive to what were issues that
were going in in the field but now I
think we're going to have a formalized
uh training schedule that will be posted
um we'll make sure that our contractors
know it we'll make sure our stakeholders
know
it when is that schedule to be posted I
don't have an exact timeline but I'll
make sure um I think one of the Senators
said who's um how do we know that these
things are getting completed but we have
to go to fiscal I think it's quarterly
and give updates on some of the reports
and I'm sure um that those that those
schedules will be included and that
information will be shared my final
question is that as you as you look at
your step staing in your
department is it is it a correct
assumption that when you hire somebody
in that department that they have field
experience that they've been a director
of special ed for example at a school
district level that they in fact
understand the law that they're not just
a casual specialed person but they have
an in depth knowledge about what's going
on yeah that's one of the um when we
interview people for positions that's um
one of the expectations and sometimes um
there have been parents that know the
process um the Ed IEP process really
well and understand all of the laws and
processes as well thank you thank you we
have a number of recommendations made by
LBA six of which may require
legislation and we're hanging on to S SP
340 right now and 443 340 is dealing
directly with
IEPs and 443 deals with transportation
services for special education
youngsters um do you have you've had
this report for a bit here now are there
any areas in which you have some
suggestions for legislation right now
that we could tack on I Can Only Hold on
these bills for at least another 30 days
and then they're out is there do we want
to use these bills as an Avenue to
trying to rectify some whether your your
needs so I mentioned the two bills that
we will need your support in to fix some
of the confusion about the statutory
requirements but I'm going to let my
teammates talk about the transportation
go yeah thank you for that opportunity
so we do have the current house bills uh
that were brought forward in response to
the audit findings um I think we do have
an opportunity to look at those Senate
bills to see if there's some areas that
we can be addressed uh I think that when
we look at these audit
findings we have to look at them in
terms of the department as a whole and
be very mindful in terms of our
implementation and and I go back to the
comment that was raised about um our
oversight and our work with the with the
leas I think that's a really important
area it is an area that is
um has a lot of opportunity and I think
it does does need to be looked at very
carefully again I go back to the
language in the audit report that the
Auditors we had a very robust discussion
with the Auditors about the Department's
oversight of the laas and historically
the department has not acted in that
capacity and so as we look into this
area which is filled with opportunity uh
I would just want to do so very
carefully so that the department does
not open it up itself up to liab ility
um but that would be the area that I
would suggest we look at and this
legislative body look at for those two
retained Senate bills I think that is a
great area to start and we appreciate
that opportunity thank you representer
Woodcock thank you chairman Dr BR thank
you for for being here and I I I
recognize as representative Miler and
luno did year competency and the
leadership and the expertise you bring
to the the department I appreciate that
but I need to say I agree with u
representative luno as I heard the last
two or three minutes of your opening
statement it's just it didn't resonate
well with me thinking that we have well
over 75% of these 20 that you that your
department agreed with of issues that
are that are uh non-compliant and in in
Era and you close with in my in my
perception well everything's fine we're
doing well and we're on track and that's
how it came to me like uh it just didn't
resonate well because I don't think
everything's fine I don't think
everything's well I don't everything's
on track and this just supports that and
this is only a two-year picture and I
you know we look at so I just I I just I
just wanted to say that I have total
faith in you but I just was taking a
step back listening to that closing well
thank you and um you know I am an
educator so I do see the um glass half
and so I think it's um I I apologize if
it doesn't uh appear that I'm taking
this serious or um I think that the
audit has pinpointed some areas that we
need to improve and need to work on and
I'm um excited that we have the tool to
make it better um but I do recognize
that there are there were some
deficiencies that they put it they put
out there but I think that um overall we
have um done my team has done a great
job making sure that people understand
this very very complicated process and
um I I apologize like I said if it was I
appreciate that thank you thank you Mr
chairman thank you rep
luno thank you very much uh Mr chair I
want to sort of go back to um uh an area
that's that's you know clearly within
the within the Department's um uh
framework and it's observation 8 which
representative lad was referring to
earlier that were
questioning whether or not the
department had um adequate Financial
controls and so this starts on page 60
but there's a there's a response from
the Department on the bottom of 64 that
that reads um so the the department
concurs in part with the recommendations
and so the response on the bottom of 64
reads um nhed will assess the need to
develop additional internal controls and
update existing policies and procedures
relating to the following contract
development identification of fraud risk
improper pay payments ability to recoup
costs for any identified improper
contract payments and contractor
payments in the appropriate um um uh
fiscal year I how is the department
going to could you sort of talk about
how the department will go about doing
that assessing the uh the need to
develop additional Financial controls
sure I mean I think right now we have a
very um wonderful CFO
at our department who oversees um our
business office and she can review um
some of the processes that we have in
place and give make sure that they are
fiscally responsible and that the
internal controls are there um and then
but what are they going to look at how
are they going to how are they going to
assess the
need assess the need for more internal
to develop additional internal control
controls well I mean I think that that's
a fiscal responsibility um and that
we'll be working with our fiscal team to
make sure that those happen I'm not a
fiscal expert but I I have full
confidence on our team um at the OBM
you representative luno if I may add to
that um I believe that the department of
administrative Services also has further
oversight on those fiscal controls and I
think those are policies that are always
being developed I'm not directly
involved in that process I personally
struggle to get my travel reimbursement
done correctly um but my understanding
from my years of employment at the
department and and within the state is
that that is an area that is beyond just
the governance unit or the Department of
Education something that the state is
constantly looking to work at um fraud
risk concerns all of us
regardless of the audit findings that's
always an issue and so it's kind of an
interplay between the office the
Department's fiscal Bureau and Das and
how that all works together but it is an
area that's constantly being uh worked
on so it's kind of our thoughts on it
but it's a much bigger picture follow up
on that Mr chair yes I yes than how how
does the the administrative Services
know when to get involved in uh in that
type of um
um you know fraud mitigation policy
review um assessing uh whether fraud uh
has has happened how does das know when
to get involved in
that I'm a little out of my depth on
that I've never worked for das um some
of it is just kind of anecdotal from
State Employment experience um I think
that there's two pieces to it there's
when fraud has occurred and that's not
what we're dealing with here that's not
the discussion um and then there's just
the constant being proactive to address
potential fraud risk
um it's important that state government
regardless of what department you're
talking about remain being proactive
rather than reactive I think that's
always a struggle for state government
and so I think just in terms of state
government as a whole
that is obviously a concern for everyone
here um and how do we make sure that our
technology our policies our practices
and our procedures are always one step
ahead to mitigate identify and detect
any fraud risk one final one final
followup on that this section
specifically relates to um to
contractors so so wondering will will
will uh Department of um administrative
Services as well as uh New Hampshire
education be able to um to um to assess
what the fraud risk is and whether fraud
has been um uh uh exists I guess whether
fraud has been committed uh uh when when
involved and thank you for the question
representative
Leno I want to be clear there was no
fraud there are areas however where the
department can be stronger in protecting
against fraud and identifying fraud risk
and that is important to the department
it's important to our
constituents and when we look at our
contract and our contract language we
will always look to strengthen that
particular
area and we'll work with the Attorney
General's office when we look at those
contracts to see where we can strengthen
it thank you thank you very much yeah
we've had a number of contracts in other
areas you know like minimum standards
for public school approval which we've
contacted with retired
superintendents some of those reports
are
sloppy and you know done on a piece of
paper and there it is and here's your 12
grand for that report I think that's
what we need to do is tighten up our
reporting to ensure that it's specific
and it answers the questions that you're
looking for
um I I've looked at a number of those
others and I was appalled that I don't
think you're doing that anymore I think
that contracted service has been stopped
but uh I agree this somewhere we have to
work on um are there any other questions
from the committee right now represent
BR go ahead represent Amon thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my
question so broad
picture does the department as it is
currently staffed and funded have the
capacity to efficiently
audit you want
us um I think that we would have to do
um a more comprehensive assessment of um
some of the um some of the things that
we found here to be able to answer that
question at this time depending on um
what route the legislation takes and
some of the things that they found in
here um for example using more of our
Authority in working with the
alas follow
yes thank you
um far more of the recommendations than
not are not identified as having
legislative involvement or potential
Solutions or
approaches so I would ask
for some sense of
timeline in the we don't know if it's 45
or 90 days 45 is really not very many or
the quarterly reporting when the
department would be able
to say we have the resources to do this
or we need these kinds of resources and
I realize this is a big picture
comprehensive question but it's the it's
the nuts and bolts of what the outcome
of this is not just a report sitting on
a
shelf exactly um it would be helpful for
us to come back after we have our
training with um the NC National Center
of improvement um systematic Improvement
this summer our whole team is going to
this along with some of the special ed
folks
and we're bringing our documents to get
great technical assistance and I think
we'll have a very comprehensive picture
of what our dispute resolution process
will look like and then we can be able
to communicate it out and make sure that
we have all the resources that are
needed we look forward to that thank you
thank you further further
questions from the committee yes
represent Hall maybe it's not a question
but thank you um first of all I taught
special editor was an Lea and this
report gives me high anxiety I mean high
anxiety I I guess I would like to thank
kind of in response to representative
Damon that the fix here and there a lot
of fixes is not going to be to hire more
people you may end up hiring more people
but I hope that's not where it's going
to start um so that that's a concern I
have about there always seems to be a
fix with hiring people and I don't think
that's the case thank you thank
you
I think the legislature sometimes has to
look in the mirror
ourselves um we had a request come in
from the Department last year for an
analyst to work with uh Caitlyn Davis
and one of our committees rejected it
came out of this committee
unanimously uh so it's uh it'd be nice
to see what your priorities are in terms
of staffing needs um for a lot of areas
so are there any other questions from
the committee here not so I want to
thank the department for thank you
coming forward and and trying to respond
to some of our questions and and thank
you very much commission brenon are
there any other groups I want is the
special education advocate here right
now Kristen are are are you do you have
any comments final comments for us
baileywick
Kristen monani Office of the advocate
for special
education um I'm not going to speak for
long but uh I did read the report as
soon as it came out it was not
surprising um I seen many of those
things in the past six plus months seven
months eight months
representing um the interest of parents
uh I would say some things I I have sat
down um with the Department um on a few
occasions prior but since this report
came out and we have
discussed where some of those fixes
should start I think one of the things
we're going to need to do is group some
of these recommendations and
observations um but you're always going
to hear me talk in specifics and not
generalizations to just to address by
way of example a couple of the things
that have come up um representative luno
for example asked a question about
timelines um and it goes to all of your
broad question about the department
concurring in part um with these
recommendations and so I would say to
use a timeline specific question but it
goes to so many of these issues what I
see is that the department
is um complying with federal regulations
and and really making good efforts in
the sense that there is a process when a
parent files for due process they get a
very way well laid out statement of here
are your timelines here's your hearing
officer here are the the dates on which
all of these things will happen and they
are compliant with the statutes and
regulations I think some of the issue
throughout this report and I I don't
know I haven't discussed this
specifically with the department but the
concurrence in part would be uh there's
not great tracking later on um and it
doesn't mean it's not happening because
my experience with the hearing officers
is that they are holding those timelines
they're very conscious of them so it
doesn't mean that we're so far off for
the majority on all of those timelines
it's that the tracking um
retrospectively of what happened in each
case isn't necessarily there um
representative cordelli asked about
nessus versus other databases being kept
by the department I I think that really
is an issue to look at how much
information could we get out of nessus
that the department could start
incorporating into its um oversight and
we have had that conversation in the P
last week in fact um and then once
they're doing some of that providing
some technical guidance to the leas
looking at information that's available
across the 30,000 student population
starting a big picture report there and
then funneling it down to better
reporting on the tracking of of the
honestly small area of dispute
resolution right because of the 30,000
special ed cases as you've correctly
pointed out there are two sides there's
another audit you know only a small
portion of them go to dispute resolution
so I I don't think the better tracking
of some of those questions is really um
as overwhelming as it might appear
initially and it's certainly something
we're discussing in terms of
recommendations because the more we
track the more we understand really the
problem and we understand where more
oversight is needed um from the
Department to the leas uh my office is
certainly going to be making
recommendations has already about some
um technical advisories we'd love to see
coming from the Department to leas on
some of these points because it is true
that a lot of them do not know um some
of the compliance pieces that they're
supposed to be ensuring at the local
level um it's come
up frequently in the past month actually
and talking about some of the findings
of this this audit but definitely
working I look forward to working in
collaboration and um I think we'll find
that some of the problems are more about
tracking and reporting and those those
metrics and that once that is done
better we'll have a better idea of how
much is substance and how much is kind
of the reporting
processes that are at issue thank you
very much are there any questions from
yes represent luno thank you Mr chair
and thanks thanks for sharing some some
some thoughts um on this I I was
wondering in in um in your experience
how how how are we doing in New
Hampshire compared with other states
like I don't know Massachusetts New
Jersey you know pick a
few and I'm talking and I'm talking
about in terms of not just the number of
complaints I mean we're at around 1% I
think just looking at the numbers um but
but the processes in general and and you
know things like
that we could tighten up some of the
processes um representative cordelli
indicated
um the tracking for example of Parental
refusals partial refusals or partial
consents depending on how you look at it
but that's going to matter in terms of
how we track it in the data whether we
track it as a partial refusal or partial
consent um those that the reporting of
those help us understand okay well let's
say only 1% are going to any kind of
complaint or dispute
resolution how should we look at that um
if we have high levels of refusals then
it's not a good thing if 1% are going
but that's the kind of data that we've
been discussing that we don't seem to
have readily available and clean just
yet that I think is doesn't have to be a
particularly difficult fix it's one of
the areas that I would like my office to
focus on in collaboration with the
Department because then we would be able
to better um answer your question
tracking refusals um some other states
are doing it much better honestly
parents refuse their IEP and they get
from um the bureaus of dispute
resolution whatever they are termed in
that state pretty quickly a letter we
understand youve refused here's a guide
here's how you go about pursuing those
rights so in that case I think you would
probably find there are fewer sitting
getting stale you know disputes or IEPs
where students are not getting Services
over a long period of time because
parents may not feel empowered to
bring a case to a resolution and in some
instances we have to provide leas with
the advice that it is their
responsibility to bring some of these
cases to resolution under the law and
that's not happening in some instances
where you could really say the laa
didn't have the right to just sit on
this dispute If the parents weren't
bringing it they needed to it had to be
resolved in some manner so that's also a
place where I'm um my office will be
working uh I hope that answers your
question do would agree further
questions thank you very much appreciate
it thank you okay with uh hearing now
from the special Advocate the department
and the LBA we want to thank people and
thank you very much for this audit
report a lot of work in it and a lot of
future work I hope comes from it thank
you very much and with that we're going
you
my
well
yeah